welcome to the makeup artist and
hairstylist symposium my name is Leonard
Engelmann I am the makeup artist and
hairstylist branch chairman Catherine
Blondell is the vice chairman and Lois
Burwell is our third governor the
nominated films this year are wonderful
examples of their very vast range that
is the art of makeup and hairstyling and
the vast range of selection process
within the makeup artists and
hairstylists branch we have bordered
Mary Queen of Scots vice today's
nominees are you're in lundström Pamela
Goldammer Jenny shirk or Mark Pilcher
Jessica Brooks greg cannom kate Bisco
and patty tahini would all of our
nominees please stand let's give them a
big round of applause
[Applause]
thank you we have a number of people in
the audience I would also like to
recognize Oscars past recipients and
nominees we have bill Corso you it if
you would stand and just remain standing
Michele Burke
Kevin Haney great Khanum barbara Lorenz
Deborah Lamia Denver Howard Berger Lois
Burwell V Neil
Trevor proud Gayle Ryan Tammy Lane
Robert pan Dini Christina Smith Martin
Samuel Roberts short Jenny shirk or and
I would also like to recognize from the
makeup artists and hairstylists guild
local 706 business representative Randy
Sayer assisted business representatives
Polly luck and patrice Madrigal and
president Julie so cash I also would
like to thank the academy is Randy
Hebert camp and Rose Wilson and the team
that they have for all the work and
coordination and making this function
take place and Tom Euler and Michael
Benedict for all of the help throughout
the entire year for our branch this
story has been told before but we feel
it's important in 1968 prior to there
being a yearly Oscar for make up Planet
of the Apes was going to receive a
special Academy Award this was there was
to be one statute the award as was the
process of the times would have gone to
the makeup department head of 20th
Century Fox dance streebek dan said the
person most responsible for this
achievement is John Chambers and he must
receive the Oscar it is that standard of
honesty and responsibility that we
follow today as the committee
painstakingly chooses the individuals
most responsible for what has been
recognized in each film a few weeks ago
the great great dance the great dance
repacked passed away but he will always
be remembered not only for his honesty
but also for his artistry this is a
wonderful time for these eight nominees
to bask in their accomplishments and
recognition some of you in the audience
may have contributed these films and
should be sharing in that glory so
audience enjoy the time applaud make
noise celebrate with these nominees
because that's what this is all about
and let's start right now
[Applause]
please welcome Katherine blonde ale
[Laughter]
today is a celebration of winners every
nominee that steps on the stage is a
winner one group will carry away a
statue but every nominee is a winner
mm-hmm
the reason the Academy gives Academy
Awards is to honor and celebrate the art
and science of the motion picture it's
why the Academy exists the Oscar exists
because the founders believe that movies
were not just a business and people
needed to be reminded of that the Oscar
exists to tell the world that filmmaking
is an art and it is being practiced by
some people at a very high level and
some of those people are in this room
today before we hear from our Oscar
nominees I would like to explain the
process that brought us here today in
April and October the makeup artists and
hairstylists executive branch meet as a
part of the business they discussed the
films that have been released during the
previous months there are films these
members feel should be seen for makeup
and hairstyling and a list is sent to
all branch members so they can be aware
of them we also encourage members to
post on our website any picture they
feel should be seen in November
all branch members are asked to attend a
meeting to discuss the list of released
films and encourage that if they have a
film that is a late release to ask their
producers to have screenings so their
film can be considered this list is also
posted along with possible new releases
then in December there is another all
branch meeting to go through the list
and to vote for the seven films that
will go forward for consideration for
the nomination these are selected as the
seven best films for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling for this year we
like to point out how unbiased these
selections are as I read out the name of
the seven films the members chose all
seven great accomplishments in our the
artistry of makeup and hair styling
black panther makeup and hair styling of
the film as a whole Bohemian Rhapsody
makeup and hair styling of the film as a
whole border makeup and hair styling for
the boar and Tina characters Mary Queen
of Scots makeup and hair styling for the
whole film stan and Ollie makeup and
hair styling for stan and Ollie
characters Suspiria makeup and hair
styling for the doctor Josef Klim / and
Halina Marcos characters vice makeup and
hair styling for the film as a whole
of 18 possible nominees seven were not
Academy members 12 or not I ATSC local
706 members four have Oscars and five
have Oscar nominations
please welcome Lois Burwell well the
selection of these films and their
possible nominees is complex for we
recognize the specific makeup and
hairstyling achievements in the film in
some cases this may be the film in its
entirety for makeup or for hairstyling
or for makeup and hairstyling or it may
be for a specific character or
characters for makeup or makeup and
hairstyling
from that decision we recognize the
artists or artists most responsible for
those achievements following that
December meeting the makeup artists and
hairstylists Executive Committee meets
this is probably the most difficult of
the meetings because the committee now
has to choose a maximum of two names and
in an exceptional circumstance proper
possibly three of those most responsible
for the look of each film or character
and characters it doesn't matter how
much was spent on advertising it doesn't
matter what someone has in their deal
memo extensive research is collated to
ensure that the executive committee
makes the decision based on input and
the work that was done then in January
all members were asked to attend a
presentation by the makeup artists and
hairstylists recognized for the seven
films this is often referred to as the
bake-off there are no baked goods and I
still don't know the answer to why is
the bake-off
this is when the final nominations were
chosen for the Academy Award for makeup
and hairstyling for 2018 as you can see
the makeup artists and hairstylists
Academy members spend a tremendous
amount of unselfish time in an effort to
applaud the work of others today you are
going to see how that process takes
place we are going to ask each of the
nominees to talk about some of the work
that took place and what and what it and
what it is you will see in the film
clips they represent
we will then show the ten-minute clip so
you can see that wonderful work after
the third clip has been seen we will
open the floor for your questions of the
nominees followed by an opportunity to
join the nominees and see the marvelous
displays representing their films
downstairs in the lobby
so now let's meet our nominees our first
nominated film is border please welcome
your in lundström urine please come up
and take a seat on the stage your and
his credit ease is makeup and
prosthetics designer and this is his
first Oscar nomination and please
welcome Pamela
gaddama Pamela is credited as onset
makeup effects and prosthetic supervisor
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Pamela
well congratulations on wonderful
marvelous work I think we can all agree
with that
so let's begin
well these are extraordinary characters
so I'd like to ask you what the
inspiration was and the design well let
me see where to start I got a phone call
from the production asking me to do
makeups for trolls for this drama and it
could only take like one hour to do the
makeup every day and so basically like
my thinking was oh I can do it like a
forehead or whatever but then I met I
got a chance to speak to the director
Ollie Abbasi about what he wanted and he
told me you know he had some ideas and
he showed me a sketch of a Neanderthal
and as a makeup artist if I'm gonna do a
troll it's really good to know what the
director wants but then I need to put my
take on what role should be and
Neanderthals looks very specific in a
sense I tried to do something that that
would be what all he wanted but not a
Neanderthal so basically script says
that the character Tina is supposed to
look very odd but still well
normal-looking to fit in into the
reality so what I had to do is like look
at the actors that we had and the hero
and look at how different they were and
tried to make them more similar looking
an era has a very strong face very
strong characters and it's kind of hard
to tone that down so what I did I tried
to make her look more like arrow but not
a Neanderthal and also there's a gender
swap thing in the whole film as well
worth she's actually the male and he's
the female well I was actually going to
ask a question of with arrow milling off
the vory character he's distinctly male
on the outside without spoiling the plot
for those people who are yet to enjoy
border so could you share details of his
makeup design
and the application well the makeup
designed for for Araucana came in second
because we counted to get the look for
four here by first and like I said he's
got very strong features as it is so
basically I just tried to make him look
less human but not always changed him
that much like whatever I would did a
lot of changes she changed her whole
whole face when it came to the gender
thing we didn't really think about the
face as much I think that came with
Martin Jacobson stuff that he did for
the body you know there was stuff there
that yes did the genders walked more yes
yes yes the giggles come from those who
have seen in the film
so apparently just for that for the for
the application so um he has forehead
peas cheeks nose he didn't have eyelids
as she did they had ear tips and they
had teeth a set of teeth each and I
placed kind of a skin flap underneath
the week so that because the week square
were quite thin and so with we could see
the skin through that I was quite
important and that at some point we'll
talk about contact lenses and just
really just before we started shooting
and the decision was not to use them
because it would just take them too far
away from getting away with stills of
being acceptable as humans it made him
look a bit too animalistic and and
that's yeah that's this makeup that's
wonderful and I believe we have a very
special guest with us today we have a
ver melanda who plays Tina ever would
you come to the stage
[Applause]
well I think we can all agree that
there's the transformation an
explanation wonderful thank you for a
wonderful performance too may I assume
think he's really exceptional so talking
about the makeup obviously now we have
the three component parts for the
character of Tina so how was it how was
it to sit in the chair every day Wow
you have to learn how to meditate how to
put your focus like far away in another
room somewhere and going there because I
mean you have to be patient and you have
to work on that a lot because I felt
like I can't afford to because after
that hours of makeup I was gonna shoot
for 10 hours so I couldn't afford to
have like big strong feelings about this
tough situation so actually I had to
meditate myself in two different places
you cannot read or watch a film or do
some studies in the manuscripts you yeah
I tried to learn how to be Buddhist monk
well done so it was also when you first
met over how much of the original design
that you had in your head did you adapt
and change forever well we did the test
makeup first just to show Ali something
he want us to see something on her right
he didn't really want to do photo shops
so I really needed to do some sort of
makeup on her and which I didn't really
feel prepared for it but what I did I
tried to find a reference some something
to look at instead of just making it up
and and I find that's a British actor
called Eddie Marsan and I kind of looked
at his face you have to get some sort of
reference because it's really it's
really easy to end up in fantasy you
know fantasy makeup and I wanted to
ground it into real
I figured if I if I used his face as a
reference so the first makeup would it
looked a lot more like him with him from
then on we did we did a risk old
completely scold and I basically has
changed the nose I think mainly you know
to make it look less like him right so
some of us would giggling because we've
worked with it yeah so yeah and and you
could you can actually see some of it
once you know who you know it's amazing
that and so being in the chair every day
and being on this set every day what was
the most difficult at day shooting from
a makeup perspective and a performance
perspective and where they both the same
performance perspective I would say that
I do play this character which has kind
of buried all her feelings inside of her
and she can't really because of her look
she can't afford to have big expressions
in her face because people will get
scared because of her teeth and how she
looks so the big challenge one of the
big challenges for me with with the
makeup was to to deliver those very
strong feelings from inside but without
using two two big expressions and I mean
normally I just have it in my face those
more muscles and you know but here I had
to like really push like the specific
feelings through the layers of
prosthetics and that that was a
challenge yes so I think for us it was
the days that were either like macro
shots like literally scan the face
really close which was the idea to bring
across strong emotions and and so we
would obviously we have such a tight
schedule so we would do these macro
shots sometimes after she's been rolling
on the floor or running up and down
chasing a fox or you know we didn't see
in the forest and very cold with very
little clothes on half-naked it's called
a right or swimming in the water so then
you know sort of different challenges
but um I think it was just the time you
know it was just a time because it was
just a little time otherwise it's sort
of you know such the usual challenges
yes yes and of course you'd be working
on on the makeup throughout the day so
in a way sometimes you must have didn't
didn't you tell me that you were quite
looking forward to close-ups towards the
end of the day rather than sometimes it
felt like that because I felt like in
the morning it wasn't enough time to get
a makeup done in the day often we didn't
have time no source of trying to catch
up all day and then sometimes I felt at
the end of the day you know it's good so
I have another question about working
collaboratively together so there's
always going to be the question of worms
that comes up sooner or later in any Q&A
now were they were they in effect were
they real how did that work they were
real but they were hygienic so you could
eat them and protein source might be our
future
so I've done some practice now but
they're actually actually one worm in
the film which was not supposed to be in
my mouth but it was just lined up in
front of me and like we just shot this
picture I just felt like this is the
best no just you know just I just have
to do it so I'm very happy we got that
in the film but I just you know there's
it's acting I didn't eat that one no I
just pretended so my question is did you
share them with the makeup department or
keep them for yourself
I kept them for myself though they
didn't ask for any so I know that there
were multiple pieces but was it was it
your own upper lip ever was that no
actually not the the upper lip
oh yes yes the upper lip was the only
part of my face which was my own even
the eyelids as you said before were
covered with prosthetics so and it was
very special since I do this character
also that the sense of smell is her
superpower and I couldn't move the mode
nose so I had to start working with
using those muscles under the nose to
push it up and also Ally was ever seeing
was talking about how horses and dogs
they have an organ of smell under the
upper lip and I started to watch sniffer
dogs on YouTube because that's basically
her job costume officer and with this
specific smell sense of smell so I just
scanned all this YouTube clips with with
the sniffer dogs and how do you know how
the nose and the lip actually go
together in one movement and that's how
I worked yes thank you so thank you very
much if you'd like to take your seats
now and then we're going to show a
ten-minute clip reel of border and the
wonderful work but thank you so much
that was the best mate thank you
[Applause]
um a small one learners
Roland hmm
selamat proper understanding for a
become you know when have your dinner
yeah I mean they have it all him some
only supposed it's involved with Billy
you name ever
thank you interpreter manao Flickerman
available it's completely split just
they did use I take it very well at all
Ensemble now they are true intellect is
awesome
my beloved is Harris on the other word
cutemon
I already Center deterrence percent
other muscle Acadia removal
assembler a box of pasta terrible Monica
pelicans demonic american-soviet from a
shameful day reading it well for a
their homeland
uh Nana
Blundell not
I'm Sara taganskaya old omelet Sunday
under under under so I refer to a better
and them never and say so
they're coming to football
this guy in Toulouse no commuter Papa
münster say
I think the research treatment in his
third wanna go in is gonna soar but it's
a video about its we're bein a yahuwah
know
don't mama Mia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with you to me not the feel of I tell
people that but comedone are born and
everyone
did you go
guarantee no
[Music]
general nothing
[Music]
No
please welcome for Mary Queen of Scots
Jenny shirk oh Jenny is credit credited
as hair and makeup designer this is the
third Oscar nomination for Jenny she won
an Oscar for Elizabeth would you join us
please and please welcome mark Pilcher
mark is credited as principal hair
artist this is the first Oscar
nomination for mark and please welcome
Jessica Brooks jessica is credited as
principal makeup artist this is the
first Oscar nomination for Jessica Jenny
make as makeup and hair designer how did
you approach during doing a historical
movie about two very complicated women
two well-known queens and all the people
that surrounded them well the easy
answer to that would be with fear and
trepidation but once that initial
feeling passes I think excitement
enthusiasm energy took over - for me -
having done the film Elizabeth and this
being of the same period to try and
breathe new life into
into Elizabeth into into the whole
period into the Tudor dynasty and with
that in mind I could then focus on a
design for both the Queen's both both
Queens both the two most powerful women
in Europe at the time and what I wanted
to do more than anything was to tell
their individual stories through hair
and makeup and the script lent itself to
that because we could actually seen by
scene working closely with the script
interpret their their emotions their
loves their losses their sadnesses their
victories their defeats all of that and
that's why perhaps in each scene both
Mary and Elizabeth have a different look
because they they go through so much
there were difficulties for me in doing
that because having done Elizabeth
before I wanted to change it change the
look not just repeat myself and Alex
burned the costume designer she
convinced me to do the film because she
said who owns it she'd also did
Elizabeth she convinced me to do it
because she said we're going to change
it we're going to make it more modern
we're going to do it completely
differently so I believed her and went
along with it
and yes I think we have done it
completely differently through mainly I
think through the journey Elizabeth
takes because this the story of
Elizabeth has been done so often and it
always ends up it has to end up with the
iconic portraiture that we all know
about Elizabeth and I didn't want to
take
the same journey to that portrait as I
had done before so we changed it through
Elizabeth's journey and through Mary's
Mary's look and Mary's hairstyles
because you never really saw Mary Queen
of Scots without her headdress on so you
never really saw her hair so I imagined
a Mary Queen of Scots without her
headdress on and devised these frames
that we use to create our hairstyles and
I think they had a great effect
they were simple to use and in fact was
good and with Elizabeth taking her on
her journey in this story she has a
small box so in the first Elizabeth we
got to that iconic portrait by showing
her as a virgin married to England nun
like so she cuts her hair off and
where's the wig but in this journey we
got to that portrait by smallpox the
journey of smallpox the boils and
blisters and the scarring that it left
and quite a Eureka moment for me was to
makeup wise was to think that not just
boils and blisters and scarring but the
placing of those boils and blisters
because transforming Margot Robbie was
when I heard that she she was cast as
Elizabeth I I didn't know whether to
laugh or cry because I didn't know how
we were going to get over there but
eventually when I didn't realize that
using boils and blisters in the placing
of those boils on her mouth when her
eyes it cetera you could then cover
those areas with makeup not anybody
would you know you've got a spot you
cover it with makeup so that is what
carried us through to being able to
transform Margo and get her to that
iconic portrait
would you say Margot was your biggest
challenge well I guess she was she was
yes getting her through to that point
yes she was technically but also in the
film the director was very adamant about
how each woman how we told the story
about each woman if one was up the other
was down so you had to be aware all the
time of the two stories running
alongside each other and to tell that
story with the way they looked hair and
makeup great how big was your team my
team we had we haven't made we weren't
quite differently in England or we can
work differently we don't necessarily
separate hair and makeup we have one
team there are those who like to
separate it but mark is a hairdresser
but he also loved sting a bit of makeup
don't you and then we have makeup in the
team who also like doing some hair so I
use the various strengths to what people
doing I think in the main team we had
six of us and then there was another
team who dealt with we dealt with the
principal's and then the other team
there were four who dealt with all the
other what we called a players and then
there was the crowd supervisor who dealt
with the dirt and the soldiers and stuff
like that great it was really good
Jessica how many Prasad prosthetics star
sorry did Margot Robbie as Queen
Elizabeth where for the different stages
and she had a nose throughout and then
for the different stages she had two
stages of smallpox one that was more
severe so she had cheeks on for that
silicon cheeks and backs of hands and
some probando pustules again
and and then for the scarring stages she
had the silicon cheeks a bald cap
Bondo's and then for the last stages we
blocked out her eyebrows with blockers
and also by thanks as well fantastic it
was quite good how long was the process
to get her through this for the scarring
stages and the smallpox stages we had I
think just over two hours um yes it was
a lot to do a lot to do in a small
amount of here mark would you talk about
the two queens looks and any problems or
discoveries you had main problems were
time factors because there were certain
days each Queen could have three or four
looks and the ADEs never want you to
take longer than a certain period of
time
and a lot of the time Jenny would we
would formulate those looks on them two
or three frames to to show the journey
that they're going through that that
particular part of the film so time
factor was the main the main thing and
also the the Scottish mountains you know
wind rain stuff like that it's not not
particularly good with hair and frames
so yes that was the main thing the main
difficult factors yeah so being a period
movie there must have been an awful lot
of wigs did you have a certain group
that you had working with those wigs to
keep them up no well we work as a team
but I would do the wigs Margo had ten
weeks so she had to plus all the frames
that had to be worked on regularly
throughout the day yeah so yeah those
frames were quite interesting I saw that
on your table and I thought that was
quite good really interesting idea well
I think they probably did use
some sort of stuffing or frames but also
it was so that we would get maximum
effect from minimum effort really once
the frames were made they were they were
dressed through the hair and they were
prepared so they were virtually her
crowns weren't they yeah we could use
one or two or don't think we ever went
to three no they were they were a
godsend really beautiful work all of you
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Madame your cousin has returned from
France her protector is Lord Bothwell
enable soldier so she comes ready for
war she may well depart once married but
I cannot profess to know her purpose
what do you see Bess
charming young
clever
confidence
she would have no trouble securing a
husband nor would I have a commoner be
king where we not in need of an heir I
have a trust you you have her affections
you can succeed good morning William
man Robert
resplendent would you
[Music]
but your queen is in Scotland's now when
my beloved Francois passed to God I
could have married any number of suitors
Portugal Denmark Sweden I decline them
all eh I said Madame No
you may remove yourself from this
council and my court
marry the beautiful Queen of Scots and
we can control them with Mary you to
become a prince if I'm noble enough for
one Queen I am noble enough for another
[Music]
do you think it might stand with my
honor to marry my sister subject surely
there can be no greater honor than to
match yourself with a nobleman by whom
you inherit such a Kingdom as England
I have such inheritance by blood we may
tell my sister that we pray for swift
peace that we may meet soon I will tell
her it once
stay with us the night at Holyrood I'm
certain mistress beaten with welcome you
come while we wish you a long and
healthy life and that no injury or
illness befall you
[Music]
[Music]
I am yours
forever yours
now
the reviews are myself suggested we have
visitors
they are Stuart's
without a treaty signed this union
strengthens her claim you need not to
condescend we are well involved before
God before all of Scotland before all
the world yes you'll be my queen
okay yes
in your master
my husband
[Music]
reckless child I have worked too long
and too hard with too much bloodshed to
secure peace this world is a brutal
place we men must be wiser not only by
the pleasure and will of God we proclaim
completes the bond of marriage between
our sovereign Mary Queen of Scotland and
the noble Prince Henry
[Music]
[Music]
we must take up arms without the
bandar-log body we must make civil war I
worked this because our swords are not
just for sure
heavens blessing we bring another Stuart
into this world heir to Scotland and to
England I might be imprisoned here alone
or may I have the company of my gentle
women you may not madam you are to
remain in this chamber then at least let
my husband remain they will take your
crime as well as mine
I shall begin again if you grant her
succession we are rewarding her
disobedience obedient she is not our
subject England does not look so
different than it's gone
they're sisters
[Music]
I am a Stewart which gives me greater
claim to England than you possess me
because I wanted to present the best
version of myself
you seem to surpass me in every way as
hadn't killed your mother I'm not my
father but you share his blood my life
she stirred me in my mind is Bertha
prayer
believe me when I tell you how it ages
me to bear such a burden Larry Stewart
is condemned to death
and we shall have peace my next one is
vice please welcome to the stage
Kate disco Kate is credited as the
department head makeup this is the first
Oscar nomination for Kate and please
welcome Patricia de Haney Patricia is
credited as the department head here and
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Patricia and please welcome gray Canada
Greg is credited as a special makeup
design created and applied by this is
the tenth Oscar nomination our great
Canada Raglan Oscars for the Curious
Case of Benjamin Button mrs. Doubtfire
and Dracula Greg also went a technical
achievement award for development of
special modified silicone material or
makeup application in motion pictures
Vice was also nominated for a BAFTA
award this year
[Applause]
well I have to start this off with a
quote if you saw the Golden Globes you
saw you saw a Christian Bale come up and
accept his award and I was watching it
and as he came up I went oh my god I
forgot what Christian Bale look like
because I had only seen him for so long
as Dick Cheney when he got up he said
and please Jim Gray Khanum and Chris
Gallagher the prosthetic sand the makeup
people on this if they hadn't done the
job absolutely brilliant
I wouldn't be here no one would give a
crap about it at all I share this with
you gentlemen and the crew as well great
job
let's take a look at the the next slide
Gregg you're working here with on on the
Dick Cheney character and tell us a
little bit about what you got involved
here and I'm no but I believe they're
silicone pieces or they're foam rubber
pieces no it's all silicone all of it
was silicone appliances we had one on
his nose he has a little divot here and
we filled that in and then rounded his
nose off and he had little plugs he'd
put up his nose to widen it a little
more and his top lip was always his and
then he had lower teeth in and when he
was older he wore contacts but then even
when he was young he had a chin
appliance to smooth out his chin and
then it went on with just cheek
appliances and a little neck waddle and
then up to where he had full neck back
of the neck and big cheap appliances and
a chin that's my eyebags
that that's it that's now I think you
mentioned something to me a couple of
days ago about something that you did
with the with the rubber grease and
tattoo color for you mixed it together
yeah it's a William Tuttle base rubber
mask grease and I discovered in India
that I accidentally one day mixed of the
illustrator liquid illustrator with the
makeup on a sponge just I call him white
stucco sponges and because I couldn't
get either one of them to fully cover
where the piece came down on the
appliance on his face in India and so I
started using it a lot now where I go in
and and mix the two and go in and and go
over we use airbrush Chris would go in
an airbrush some illustrator colors and
then I go in and touch certain areas up
and it really blends
the two of them really blend well but
still keeping it very thin and then I go
over at the end with the rubber
masteries to give a little nice shine
and a little trance very thin very
translucent look to it so you can see
through it and then the last thing is
the Reds I go ahead and punch up to all
the Reds you did something interesting
with with baldies I believe also yes
Chris did that he we shot him 21 with
his hair and then once it was in the can
he they shaved his head every day and he
would shave it and get it down and then
we'd use pax Mel packs paint on it to
three colors to get it looking like his
skin color and everything and then Chris
had going in airbrush some baldies
thinned out baldies so you wouldn't get
the hair growth during the day and it
worked fantastic and the wigs worked
really well with it and it really made
it natural-looking
and you you had the different looks here
let's go back to the 27 and 33 different
looks here and a lot of that those looks
were also done with the with the hair
pieces and Patti I think you were
overseeing but it was it Karen Karen
Meyers who was applying yes for all of
the Christian Bale characters yes Karen
did a lot of the application we both
were together in the mornings we'd go
over which wigs were working for the day
and it truly was a job that took all
hands we needed four hands for the jobs
because once the hair was shaved off the
wigs didn't quite fit as well so we did
when you go out to the lobby you can see
especially in the older wigs there's a
lot of little flaps that we had a cut
and darts here and there so one of us
would be holding the piece out and the
other one would get the brush in the
in there and quickly nothing's down so
it definitely took two people some of
the times to do that Karen was just her
work is just so precise and I knew she
was the right person for this job
right you can see in these in these
clips here the difference between age 27
and 23 where the the sideburn comes down
a little bit further a little bit
different shape you know it just
subtleties that were there all the way
through and then let's take a look at
the next clip now here we've got him in
any older look and and Greggy you were
talking about some of the the changes
here so just go through briefly if you
would
you've got next pieces and I think that
neck piece goes all the way around
underneath in the back yeah and a big
big piece in the back for the rolls and
that which we didn't so decide on till
the first day of shooting when we
finally put the whole thing on it was
the River shoot and we just went he
needs the back of the neck so we hadn't
taken a full head cast so he just took
him kept the neck on and took FA a back
piece thing and then sculpt it and went
from there but thirty five and forty was
when he got into office and that's when
people started seeing him when he was
young nobody knew what he looked like
and then as he of course got to the
famous look and when he was older 65 68
when they started they didn't nobody
thought we could pull this off like this
and they just wanted an essence of
Cheney of course in in Christian like
happens with a lot of makeups and but as
it went along and Christian really got
into the prosthetics and everything and
we did tests and
then he kept pushing sing a stronger
fatter neck he was really into a strong
neck and he really wanted to just be you
so you didn't notice him he just would
blend in the background that's what he
really wanted to look like and so it
just progressed to you know as myself
being a makeup artist I really wanted to
go for it and luckily Christian let us
go that far and it just all came
together we had six weeks great pull it
off and it worked that's great let's
take a look at the the next the next set
of film here now here we've got Amy at
age 43 and Lynn at age 72 and Kate and
and Patti I know you two were involved
together in making some of these changes
let's discuss this older look first we
did the fracture up on her which used to
be part of our dirty man toast remember
that I remember it very well so if I
also remember seeing this on different
actresses that I worked with it's a
great technique if there's hairstyles
here that him and learn this technique
it really does come in handy for someone
but the amount of hair that Amy Adams
has so that you can make a nice head
shape out of it also learned some great
techniques from Renata of how to tighten
up areas to me maybe pull the skin back
a little bit which we used for the early
Lynn Cheney and then this helped us this
Kate will explain with the lips okay
let's go back one went okay now here
we've got a nice look to the 23 and the
54 and and Kate what have we got going
here with the with the 23 as an example
because she looks so lovely
Amy's very young looking anyway she has
amazing skin so what we tried to do we
did use list to get this eyebrow shape
and also on the neck and we did all of
her makeup everything was on top all of
our makeup was on top her lips were a
hire brows were higher just everything
was up and then the later years
everything was drawn on down lip shape
was drawn very very underneath my makeup
nothing this one so much button later
stuff all the eye makeup was underneath
and then lifts again because it was
never discussed publicly that there was
this facelift and it was never mentioned
in the script it was just look weird if
we went kind of all the way so it had to
be subtle enough so that it did look
like her but not you know blatant
because otherwise it would just look
weird but so but if you look at Lynn
Cheney her eyebrows just kept getting
further and further apart the same way
her hairline kept kept going back back
back mostly during the presidency so at
that point all of her makeup was the
details were all underneath and the
eyebrows got wider and now here also I
believe we've got a great deal of
stretch and stipple and also appliance
underneath the the jaw line let's go
let's go back to where we were yes I
would do the stipple for this this
doesn't have the appliance yet this is
just some stretch and stipple okay and
this was mostly made because she had
daughters who she's actually quite close
to an age in real life in the actresses
they're all kind of in the same age
range we kind of had to in her forties
age her just to make that age gap
between the actresses who are playing
teenagers so to make that age gap
believable we've really had to push her
age so this is just a little bit of
stretching stubble around the eyes and
around the mouth okay and then let's
let's look two more photos forward okay
just stop right here now here we see you
working on
on Lynn Cheney and we see you working on
Condoleezza Rice let's go to the next
next slide now this is interesting
so we see the Lisa gay Hamilton we see
Lisa hey Lisa gay Hamilton with marks
all over her face and then we see
Condoleezza Rice so I thought it was
interesting the which you had said
before about how you sort of create some
of the characters take a photo and then
you you go in with doing some sketching
so I kind of just drawn there kind of
what needs to be done and see what I can
do especially if it's gonna be an out of
the kid thing it has to be done it
painted so and that's what this was it
was in my mind I tried to think before
even looking at research pictures I
tried to think of what were those
triggers of Condoleezza Rice that I know
as her being an iconic figure see Lynne
Cheney wasn't really known to the
general public as much as she was so I
kind of thought gap in the teeth and the
furrowed brow and then when did the
research and so I knew that those were
the things that I really had to get and
of course Lisa Gaines so smooth and so
tons and tons of layers of stretch and
stipple and glued her eyelids down to
make that hooded eyelid so it kind of
glued them with Telesis and foot stretch
and stipple all over them and just made
him as heavy and heavy as possible and
then her and Lisa gates nose was much
wider so I took third-degree silicone
and closed her nostrils to make it just
their nostrils look much much smaller
stretch and step all over and then
figured out how to asking advice from
Tony Jean then bill Corso how to do
those little raised freckles little skin
tag freckles and it was a really thick
in bondo with eye shadow over it right
well there were so many historic
characters we've got Steve Carell as
Donald Rumsfeld we got Tyler Perry as
Colin
we've got hot damn in george w bush
jamie
by jamie Killman Osama bin Laden and so
many other characters really an amazing
job let's see one more here we've got a
group shot of some of the group and
creating some wonderful wig there so
thank you very much for being here
[Applause]
situation is extremely this can be a
great opportunity an opportunity to work
in the hallways of decision making and
the most powerful country in the goddamn
world I believe I may have a way to put
an oar in the water on Russia what if we
create President Henry let's you're a
dick out one of Dick Cheney's special
superpowers was the ability to make the
most wild and extreme ideas sound
measured and professional but much more
enjoyable hmm I do like a good puppet
show I say we do it I will not let you
down you can count on me
and thank you do believe I have to go to
about the hospital now
very very
you're not thank you see what I think is
okay over there great to see you both
hug to the girls george w black sheep of
the family conditional love there hello
George
it's been a while unless you
foreign-policy sessions that's right
yeah that's right those meetings were
very engaging they remember both greed
my dad would have been reelected and
taken out Saddam right yeah wartime
presidents very popular two times two
times I have to drag you out of it GL
like a filthy hobo oh I'm sorry Lana
what what did you just say oh sorry
Lenny you're sorry
don't call me Lenny you're sorry
one time is I'm sorry two times makes me
think that I've picked the wrong man you
already got your ass thrown out of Yale
for drinking and fighting I know you're
just gonna be a lush that hangs
powerlines for the state are you gonna
live in a trailer we're gonna have 10
kids is that the plans flaming a tongue
trick and dick would wait backstage with
that bucket of water so I'm at the state
finals and I throw up the baton and it
doesn't come down wrestles please you
need to remember that if you have power
people will always try to take it from
you always yes ma'am
remember that Don Rumsfeld please this
is a tragedy that is our president
ridiculously think this could be very
very good news
dick was becoming sharper and sharper as
a DC insider and when had started to
write articles and explore ideas for
first novel dick dick
then she received news from back home in
Casper there was never a serious
investigation until in his mom's death
want to see me do a handstand I can do
she broke up with me well dad I like
girls I'm gay
it doesn't matter sweetheart we love you
no matter what the vice president is a
nothing job how many steps ahead was he
looking how did he feel about the
opportunity that was in front of him
there are certain moments so delicate
like a tea cup and saucer stacked on a
teacup and saucer on p'tee cup and
saucer sense that you're a kinetic
leader you make decisions based on
instinct oh maybe I can handle some of
the more mundane jobs overseeing
bureaucracy managing military energy
foreign policy
that sounds good is being evacuated
we're told and clearly that that shot
that I need you to take me to dick
CIA on their international coalition the
Taliban took Afghanistan in a matter of
weeks Cheney found something much more
powerful than missiles or jet planes a
focus group show people still aren't
sure about a connection between Saddam
and al-qaeda and the France and Germany
have both said that they will not join
our coalition and neither will Israel
Sircar we want to move in a lot in in
Afghanistan
did he or did he not meet with al-qaeda
but sir Colleen had vowed to kill all
Shia Muslims and bin Laden's mother was
Shia so the meeting didn't go over well
Iraq today harbors a deadly terrorist
network headed by Abu Musab al-zarqawi
an associate and Calabrian address was
seen by millions of Americans but other
people were watching as well the great
general of America sang his name over
and over again
we made Zarqawi a star staying at the
Capitol prison watch you step down I
appreciate your service
well does uh Bush's kid want me out or
do you I can't win every fight none you
were a little piece of [ __ ] sorry
your heart just isn't pumping enough
oxygen to keep your vital organs alive
should I call for a minister no no he's
not going anywhere
Dick Cheney you are not going anywhere
do you hear me so don't you care what
the American people think no I think you
cannot be blown off course
I can feel your recriminations and your
judgment and I am fine with it you want
to be loved you'll be a movie star
you chose me well I did what you asked
please come back on the stage let's give
them another round of applause we start
our question-and-answer period there are
individuals in the aisle and they have
microphones so if you are have a
question that you want to ask please
raise your hand he'll bring the
microphone over so that everybody can
hear what your question is so I'm gonna
start off just with a question such
great work how do you ask a question I
was very much taken with Elizabeth in
Mary Queen of Scots with the sort of
pockmark look that was done whoa what
what did you use for that
scouring stage we had silicon cheeks and
and we also had pre bondi molds as well
and yeah they were just and obviously
that was then painted up why as well for
the when she covered her pop marks okay
question from the audience
here have one we have a question oh hey
sorry over here first of all
congratulations to all of you for the
nomination so my question is about the
final effect of a makeup look is
dependent on many other factors of the
film so for instance lighting angles
editing all of those things so I wanted
to basically ask how was your process of
working with all these other departments
if there is any and where the challenges
that you possibly face it doesn't have
to be about the specific movie that you
have been nominated for it can be just
in your career an experience in general
thank you well I think I'll take that
just because it's sort of a general
general question ideally you want to
have a great collaboration between
makeup hair styling costume
cinematography because as many use of
you know if the lighting is incorrect it
can make somebody look older and if
you're trying to make somebody look
older and the lighting is incorrect it
could make them look younger so it's
it's certainly something that has to
ideally be a collaboration and when you
have that collaboration then then that
it all works together
another question does this elaborate
makeup have to be put on and taken off
every day for a period of weeks well we
shot four I mean I think it was about
fifty times we did the makeup and a lot
of days we'd have to do to makeups
because of the the location we'd need to
do a younger makeup and then the older
makeup it was different all the time but
a lot of days we would completely take
him out of one makeup and put him into
another makeup and it was many hours of
day of course then but it was the only
way to do it and you have to do it takes
you know whatever length it takes to do
it right we had several people working
on them at
I'm and but it you just have to do it as
fast as you can and do it okay
another question so I think that the the
just paraphrase that sorry chime in but
basically yes
you don't reuse pieces if there was of
that part to your question you don't
reuse pieces unless you know you really
have to and then you really don't want
to because they look dreadful you might
be able to pop them on a double way up
there on a mountain but you don't want
to do a close-up on it question here I
congratulations something your
nomination I hope you all win I just
wanted to ask you have you ever had a
case where actors develop an allergy to
makeup and they have to keep on wearing
them who wants to jump on that one I
mean I have a lot of people are allergic
to old-age stipple which is made from
latex and I've been in the middle of the
film anthony mackie in Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter Lois got to do the real
Abraham Lincoln at Spielberg but
but halfway through the film the spots
and everything I was doing then the
areas of the stipple he just a rash read
and so luckily it was towards the end
and I just had to completely switch over
to theatrical makeup painting at all and
making it look the same with paint
anybody else with a problem like that
yeah I can't imagine we all haven't had
a cape yes on sharp objects it might
have been Amy's and my hastily trying to
remove those words from her arms and we
removed the word the next day she came
in that word was still there but there
was no makeup there so we were a little
bit more gentle the next time okay going
back to the question before about you
know the the appliances and can you use
it over as careful as you are in putting
the appliance on you're just just
careful and taking the appliance off
because you're gonna be using that skin
for days after days so another question
I have a question over here alright are
there any specific makeup brands that
cover up surgical scars for actors
band-aids okay anybody have an answer
for that
well there I mean I'll have a go that if
you like I mean they're the the thicker
make up odor McHale actually derma
palates were originally created
specifically as a camouflage palette for
medical use or medical associated use
you know whether it was a birthmark or
scarring so yes there are we're not
about to tell one brand over another up
here not unless we get an awful lot of
money to do so but no seriously knowing
that we can't do that but yeah but yes
there are yes that liquid bandage we've
used a lot when things happen I've been
on a show where the actor instead of
letting me touch up the dirt grabbed a
handful near the tree and went like this
and then poison ivy on his forehead and
then they go you have to cover it I go I
ain't touching it you take him to a
doctor you do whatever I am not touching
it and I wouldn't because it can get
infected or whatever okay another
question I have another question over
here
hi um oh wow that's loud first off
congratulations on your nominations and
my question is what is the hardest and
most elaborate makeup look you've ever
done this is for whoever feels like
answering it
the film's they just did for me Robert
Downey jr. in fur and what was involved
in that makeup
he played somebody who had
hypertrichosis or hirsutism also covered
head-to-toe in hair a circus sideshow
performer anybody else that had that
unusually difficult one even more
difficult than what you've done I always
say the hardest one I've ever done was
Sigourney Weaver and alien 3 she had
shot and shaved her head down to stubble
and they needed to do the new ending and
everything and I go I don't know I've
never done this before I don't think
anybody had and I we did a thin and we
only had phone rubber then and we did a
thin thin bald cap out of latex and
Stewart arting Stoll spent 12 12 2 weeks
10 hours a day punching each hair into
it and then I would shave it down to
stubble and have to go in and thicken it
a bit and trying to get and she had
really thick hair that had grown out and
she didn't want to shave it and it took
me an hour and a half just to get her
hair down with gafquat and Gant res and
it was the hardest trying to line it up
here really thin and make it work was
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life anyone else with a major
accomplishment
okay another question I have a question
over here thank you
hi I have a question for my fellow Swede
Yaron what did you use for the
prosthetics what material did you use
for border yeah well we we usually use
Platteville but for this one I wanted to
try because plat still has some issues
depending on where interface you put it
you could get a little crinkle and
around the mouth especially so for this
one we put I use gelatin for the chin I
started like that and see if that worked
and then yeah I really liked it our
actress and so I felt that maybe we
should try for the cheeks this was we
actually have a mix of silicon for
silicon nose and gelatin cheeks and
gelatin chin which is kind of rare today
but it it did help with that problem but
you always get another problem if you
use another material so because the cold
I heard that there was one day wasn't it
we had a problem because gelatin softens
with the body heat but when it's cold
it's stiffens yeah we had this one day
during a sex scene that was really cold
and obviously there was so much sort of
touching and rubbing biting and Wescott
tricky but then for the day for the days
we were in the water
I ordered silicon pieces because gelatin
and water can be tricky
all right another question have another
one you're all so wonderful and at the
top of your field it's a real honor to
be here with you today so thank you so
much for all the art that you've brought
to the movies that we love I have a
general question though because you are
at the top of your field do you find
that when you have your concept for a
movie that that concept and vision is
accepted pretty much across the board or
do you still have times where you find
you have to compromise quite a bit Jenny
you want to jump on that one
yes I normally find if I have a concept
for a movie and it is completely right
and just in my mind of the way I should
be doing it then I feel I could fight
off any director or producer to accept
my concept and I haven't failed so far
so change what about you I don't know if
I've had the same experience as you I I
think I'm just a real slow learner I
feel like I never get a character until
like two weeks into the movie and I've
been lucky enough to have very
collaborative directors and costume
designers production tires and hair
stylists and actors so it's always an
ongoing process I mean I got to hand it
to people who do TV I am a fish out of
water because I can never come up with
something that fast so for me it's a
long-term collaboration you're in
okay I don't really do like this is an
exceptional film for me because I don't
really do a full design job for a film
so I don't really have to you know fight
for my ideas like that and Greg I know
that you often have changes after
changes and tests or maybe not tests and
maybe a changes during the movie yeah
and I always have done what I want I
don't care what the director or because
they usually have no concept of it I go
in and I design what I want and then
they've almost always have gone oh
that's great it's perfect then I go but
like Coppola Dracula he I would show him
three different heads for the wolf
creature and he goes I know nothing
about makeup effects you do whatever you
want so I would choose everything and I
that's the kind of director we want for
all the time isn't it okay we've got
we've got time for one more question I
got a question over here congratulations
on your nominations my question is sort
of a more technical I have two questions
so I'm just going to ask a combined with
the heavier pieces for the prosthetics
is there anything like an option for the
actors to get any time to practice with
them to like work on their ammo ting or
anything like that and secondly how did
you get the silicone pieces to survive
in water for border thank you the
silicone pieces days of AI fine and
water that's not a problem and that's
why it's more tricky with the gelatin
but um it's been fine for the rest of
the shoot what was the first part of the
question I think that's different I
don't know if we had any because you you
basically I handed over the makeup two
days before we started shooting so I
don't think he ever got any time to
rehearse for this one but test filming
once yeah but it's not usually a lot of
rehearsal time at least about my
experience I don't know if Greg for some
bigger budget movies that I do so you
might might have more time I don't know
well we try I mean there's people like
gary oldman night when i did Hannibal
and I never saw him rehearse I never saw
him rehearsing the bat creature suit and
he just gets out there and does it and I
just be uh you know amazing how he would
just instinctively do it never some but
like Christian we would make him up days
at his house and he'd just spend the day
in it in front of mirrors and that and
then he was always working on it in the
mirror when we'd be making him up he'd
just the research and watching Jani and
then practicing and it was really
fascinating to get to see him learn all
that with his character so but usually
we don't have time much to do rehearsing
with makeups
okay wonderful wonderful work from all
of you this year just just outstanding
[Applause]